congratulations on this film i laughed i
think it's i you know i thought it was
very relatable and i think a lot of
people are going to find it relatable
what was the inspiration behind the
story
uh it is not autobiographical but i
think after having done uh this we made
it 10 years ago we made a film
that was kind of about sexual
insecurity let's say in your 30s
and uh i think there was lots to revisit
about how that changes as we get older
um and sort of listening to stories of
you know my friends and colleagues other
people other people about what was going
on with their lives and their sex lives
and their marriages and having kids and
how that changes them
i started to cobble together sort of
ideas based on that and i was really
happy to reunite with her it's kind of
perfect
yeah so we can say it was my awkward
sexual adventures you guys ten years ago
so we're back at tiff again with this
did you write this part with emily in
mind i think probably subconsciously i
did
um
i was kind of writing it originally what
it was originally around the same time
that we were making that film
and uh it wasn't it kind of came back
around when we came back around to it
and it was time to actually make the
movie as soon as we said her name sean
the director and i we shawn said my name
and it was
like
yeah and then we looked her up and then
i was like oh right she was in that
other movie we did yeah and then
and then we reached out
is it easy for you because you have this
relationship when you're on when you're
making this chemistry come alive on
screen
yes
i mean
this
well i even remember when we did my
awkward sexual adventure i was kind of
at a point where i
i
didn't like acting anymore i remember i
kind of wanted to quit before that and
working with sean was something that
renewed my
love of acting um and so going into this
i just felt like
even before i read the script i was like
oh i just want
not with you but with shaw i just i he
makes me better he makes everybody
better and working with jonas
that kind of like
i don't know connection we have
off screen um
can't not be on screen because he's
looking at me the way he is right now
and it's weird and all so yeah it's just
it's great yeah which is good because
the internet thinks you're married
anyway yes thank you for pointing that
out it does yeah we're not married no
and i really want people to know that
yeah it's important that people know for
me to know that i am not married to you
yeah we have much more of a brother
sister yes kind of vibe i think which
actually
works it does but now i'm thinking it's
weird because we did all the sex stuff
together
so we don't know we want people to think
about that yeah and the big premieres
tonight on a scale of one to ten how are
the nerves right now for both of you i'm
not nervous i hadn't even thought about
it until you just brought it up you just
went from a zero to a ten thank you yeah
i'm excited for people to see it i do
feel like
it's because i watched it recently again
um and it's just i feel like there
hasn't been a movie like this in a while
where
you know it's it's not a marvel movie
it's like those
old kind of like knocked up or this is
40 like they haven't made those kinds of
just
funny
movies in a while it's really audience
friendly like i think we were aware we
were aware of that when we were making
it like we're making something that's
relatable that's funny it's raunchy it's
you know a little surprising i think and
it's got a lot of heart so it's the kind
of movie where i'm not nervous to watch
it with an audience yeah i'm excited to
watch it without i think it's very
different you make like an art film oh
yeah and you're nervous because you're
like people could just hate this but
this is a lovable kind of fun romp yeah
if i may and it's fantastic during tiff
and i mean we as canadians we've got
this legacy of cinema but it's often
dark yeah this is so much fun what do
you think audiences are going to you
know walk out of this what are the
conversations they're going to have
after watching it
i think that'll stir up a lot i think i
think it'll stir up a lot of
conversation most people that see it
that are in long-term relationships or
have kids or have been in a long-term
relationship
they they kind of look at you with a bit
like with a bit of a wink and go wow
like yeah i get it i got that there's
something there's just something kind of
universal in it that i think people are
connecting to um and that's what we were
trying to do i think was just by being
as specific as we can really trying to
tell a story that relates to everybody
is there a single person that you are
really excited to have watch this who
can't like whose opinion can't you wait
for
oh my um
well
it's weird because she's right there
and it's my agent who has been my agent
since the beginning um
i was her first booking um and i care a
lot about what she thinks because she
can't hit me so i know
she's not gonna fake laugh like danny
can only real laugh and i think she's
gonna love it
so i'm really excited for her to see it
for me it's probably steven spielberg i
know at the same time he has his own
premiere of some sort down the road but
i just feel like he's going to bow out
of that yes and come and just check ours
out and then that's when our thing is
going to start him and i are going to
have a thing yeah for sure his movie is
a semi-auto autobiographical he knows
what that's right and he's watched it a
billion times because when you edit it
you have to watch the million times he
doesn't want to watch it again he's
gonna come check out our it's gonna be
great
well congratulations and have fun
tonight i thought it was great i laughed
a lot during it so thank you so much for
coming